et maintenant voici mon CDD Tom villa
la musique
tu rentres sans musique oui c'est le
meuble
de musique
si vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
attention Tom
[Musique]
mon petit c'est bien c'est mieux c'est
mieux c'est mieux ça va tout le monde va
bien
et comme c'est la tradition à faire un
petit débrief des tweets de la semaine
dernière n'hésitez pas à commenter les
missions en direct # slt sur Twitter on
les lira la semaine prochaine parmi les
questions de la semaine dernière une
question de Sylvanus qui nous demande
il y a le nom qui qui l'a choisi on est
sur Twitter pourquoi est-il tout le
temps habillé en noir Ardisson pour être
sûr qu'on le reconnaisse
c'est comme Cousteau avec son chapeau
c'est comme couche-toi avec le bonnet
rouge c'est comme cela le géant vert il
est en vert et puis le matin je vais
dire c'est quand même beaucoup plus
simple de prendre le costume qui sort du
pressing je me fais jamais chier pour
habiller moi vous n'avez plus de toi non
plus remarqué
bon en tout cas très bonne question de
Sylvanus là la semaine prochaine on
répond à la question pourquoi qui me
Kardashian est toujours habillé en [__]
une
c'est un peu vrai
tu as de la chance qu'elle soit partie
une remarque aussi d'un twitto ce qui
nous dit impossible d'avoir accès au
replay depuis la Belgique dommage c'est
fou Twitter parce qu'avec les pseudos on
pense passer inaperçu et dis donc Arthur
tu crois qu'on t'a pas reconnu bah
démerde-toi mon vieux
et puis il y a eu un très beau sondage
aussi lancé par le Twitter de Salut les
Terriens suite au débat sur le naturisme
de la semaine dernière la question était
la suivante le naturisme en ville vous
en pensez quoi il y a quand même eu 32%
qui ont répondu oui si c'est bien
délimité ah voilà donc moi le seul
avantage que je vois que le naturisme en
ville c'est que s'il y a un connard qui
vient avec un gilet d'explosif on
devrait le remarquer plus vite reste à
savoir où il a rangé le détonateur et
mon petit homme et puis Thierry c'était
l'affaire de la semaine c'est le
possible retour de Laurent Baffie dans
Salut les Terriens
tout le monde en a parlé Télé 7 Jours
qui a dit Salut les Terriens le retour
de Baffie et Cardi son Télé Star qui a
dit Laurent Baffie bientôt et Cardi son
dans cellule et terrien gala Laurent
Baffie était Ardisson se remettent en
couple et il y avait eu des titres un
peu plus confidentiels que j'ai trouvé
sur internet il y a cuisine magazine qui
nous dit belle fille de retour à
cardisson c'est dans les vieux pots
qu'on fait les miroirs et même sanglier
passion qui nous dit Ardisson Baffie
nous on s'en bat les glands
donc voilà donc retour de Laurent Baffie
possiblement possiblement à noter aussi
en novembre le retour du professeur
Rollin
décembre le retour de Corti pour les
blind test
en janvier le retour à vos côtés linda
Hardy ça lui changera du shopping de
Montargis donc n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer vos messages pendant l'émission
hashtag slt merci
[Musique]
j'adore cette musique
Claude François là
c'est pas mal M Pokora qui sera bientôt
notre invité d'ailleurs alors vas-y
un plateau magnifique ce soir il est
l'un des animateurs préférés des
français il adore les chiens il fait le
bonheur de français les vision ce n'est
pas Michel Drucker mais Stéphane Bern
mesdames et messieurs
ah oui
alors Stéphane Bern évidemment c'est
l'histoire et à chaque fois on vous vend
comme le spécialiste des têtes qu'on est
c'est vrai c'est fans c'est celui qui
connaît la taille précise les oreilles
du prince Charles le nombre de cheveux
qui reste sur la tête du prince William
et le nombre d'orgasmes qui a eu la
reine d'Angleterre au cours de sa vie
bah c'est facile Elisabeth 2 c'est dans
son nom
vous êtes là ce soir pour votre livre
secret d'histoire numéro 7 le 7e ils
sont arrêtés au 5 et c'est beaucoup mais
moi j'adore regarder particulièrement
l'émission secrète d'histoire sur France
2 parce que Stéphane Bern c'est quand
même l'un des rares animateurs à voir la
capacité de pouvoir parler et de marcher
en même temps comme Bernard de la
Villardière on sauve que vous derrière
vous il y a pas un camp de gitan ou une
favela
et puis Stéphane quand il nous parle des
[__] les meufs elles ont connu Louis
XIV
un petit peu j'ai découvert que
l'histoire sans vous depuis tout petit
votre premier boulot d'été c'était homme
pipi au château de Versailles c'est
mignon il était naïf à l'époque on lui a
vendu la salle du trône à la base
et puis vous avez dit le point positif
de cette expérience et dans toutes les
langues je sais dire le mot les
toilettes voilà et comment ça se dit la
chasse d'eau [__] en japonais alors
Stéphane Bern c'est les têtes pour René
oui mais c'est aussi les fêtes mondaines
en juillet dernier vous étiez à
l'anniversaire de Line Renaud bon en
même temps le temps qu'elle s'ouvre
toutes les bougies on était fin août et
vous aviez croisé Emmanuel Macron
l'anniversaire de Line Renaud en même
temps c'est normal c'est une amie
d'enfance de sa femme donc oh non
[Applaudissements]
Lambert Wilson bonsoir c'est l'un des
de nos plus grands comédiens en France
voilà vous venez pour votre nouveau film
qui s'appelle l'Odyssée c'est sur la vie
du Commandant Cousteau alors le
commandant Cousteau on l'oublie mais
c'est quand même le tout premier hipster
de l'histoire un petit bonnet il est pop
et des lunettes fumées on apprend plein
de trucs qu'on ignorait dans le film par
exemple le Cousteau avait une double vie
trompait sa femme donc en plus des
poissons il aimait les crustacés et
au cinéma que des grandes figures de ce
siècle l'abbé Pierre ou l'avait dit dans
hiver 54 le commandant Cousteau dans
l'Odyssée en fait j'ai compris la
carrière de Lambert c'est pas une
filmographie qui veut c'est juste le
classement du JDD tu sais et je suis
impatient de vous voir en Omar Sy
Fauve Hautot
je rassure pas de jeux de mots sur votre
prénom vos parents vous ont appelé fauve
à cause de l'amour en héritage et c'est
vrai que c'est dramatique toute cette
génération qui a eu des prénoms à cause
des séries comme ça Beverly Beverly
Hills c'est tout moi j'ai la sœur d'un
pote elle s'appelle Manimal c'est chaud
quand même
alors faut vous êtes devenu une star
grâce à Danse avec les stars premier
partenaire c'est Jean-Marie Bigard je te
remercier cette émission parce que ça
faisait longtemps que Bigard nous avait
pas fait marrer comme ça et maintenant
vous faites partie du jury alors pour
être embauché je crois Danse avec les
Stars vous allez menti sur votre CV
c'est ça
vous avez d'autres points communs
Rachida Dati ou
alors Thierry on dit souvent que danser
avec les stars il y a que ceux qui sont
devenus ringard qui le font dans ces
c'est pas vrai non cette année il y a
Julien Lepers il a jamais été à la mode
du tout le père ça voilà Mesdames
Messieurs je suis ici pour vous poser
les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
Stéphane Bern il paraît que vous êtes
tellement à fond dans les têtes
couronnées que lorsque c'est pas vous
qui tirez la fève à la galette des rois
vous êtes dégoûté
non je l'avale pour laisser la couronne
aux autres tout savoir et pour terminer
fauve vous avez dit je carbure à la vie
et à la joie de vivre vous avez d'autres
phrases de Miss France ou c'est la seule
comme ça mais oui mais je suis comme ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu